If you dream of standing ovations, gold medals...
...and record-breaking times,...
...know one thing.
The track to glory won't always be clear.
There will be bumps along the way.
Tears will be shed,...
...limbs will be bruised...
...and so will egos.
But however hard you fall,...
...however bad you fail,...
...you must always get up again.
Up again.
To rule the ice, you need to silence the critics,...
...including the ones in your own head.
Be proud of who you are.
When others want you to hide,...
...don't be afraid of what might happen.
Embrace the future instead.
Because to be a champion like me,...
"From Spain, Javier Fernandez"
...to reach a higher level, you have to take risks...
...and learn from your mistakes.
Only then will you get up again.
Up again.